un dato importante porque la empresa
civil
Muccia contacto con el mundo empresarial
botella grande de pergamino del dias e
el abogado Silvio almeida negro e
escritor autor de un libro
fundamental en el panorama intelectual
Debora Silly llamó racismo y
Lago Estructural Tenemos es el Ministerio
del Guardaracial Agnelli Franco
persona muy simbolica eslair romana
de la consagración Marielli Franco que fue
asesinado
biblioteca negra
el director del Instituto Mariella e
franco tamiens recuperar el ministerio de
cultura que tiene vía sidosurimido Porro
bolsonaro del momento no sabia que soy
vía chimbaceir y el ministro de medio
ambiente un sombreado Muriel
internacional se creó recientemente a partir de
a través de los ministerios tan promessito de
pueblos originales y tienes un grande
momento En el panorama Simone Tebeci che
se colocó la Tercera Era y la corrida
presidencial ayudando mucho a los Lula
en la segunda y la segunda Vuelta y la
campaña y que asombrado nos presenta y la
ceremonia y Lula también sobrevivieron Y el
diploma de los presidentes El dosis de
Diciembre
a
ministerio y en el nuevo tipo